[Music]
kentucky
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right man let me hear your voice i
want to see how loud you are how loud
are we perfect perfect perfect
i knew a little louder if you help me no
i'm sure
i'm sure you will with the right
questions
all right mountain man yeah man where'd
you grow up where you from originally
right here on straight creek buddy
this is the only place to grow up on the
street great
tell me about your family you had both
your parents growing up yeah dad now
well dad and him was raised here around
here
and uh we was up the road down a little
ways
where dad went in when he got married we
were all raised up there but this is
grandma's and dad's old house place
really how would you describe your
childhood
beautiful i we had all great
fun running up down this road here but
if we went too far we went fishing one
day
dad said don't go no further than the
water gap boys
we go down the road we go on by the
water gap you know we're catching fish
we all by the water gap it's really
getting about this time late and eating
getting dark
and uh we looked up the road
here come dad but a limb was swapping it
on his leg
oh we know we figured he wouldn't whip
us you know
get us caught with him how big stranger
a fish
he wore us out and said now boys go home
clean the fish and we'll eat them
he said i told you not to go no further
than water gas we figured we'd get by
without uh getting a whipping if we had
that big string or a fish
so we we we got what we didn't deserve
because we disobeyed him you know didn't
do what he said
and if you these old timers if you
didn't do what they said
you got to whip it huh what is a
whipping
uh wiring out with a limb and most of
the time you had to go
cut it and get your limb to be wet with
we go get one of them little king winter
limbs so they'd break quick and quit
whipping uh
how do you how do you say it appalachia
or appalachia
uh appalachian or whatever yeah and uh
it's a beautiful part of the country
yeah there i
i went there nowhere else they're very
poor though yeah
tell me tell me about how you grew up
you grew up with electricity and running
water and stuff like that
we know we didn't have no electricity it
had old lake crowd we're running water
either we run it down
got it out of spain but they obviously
got
uh electricity up through here
they had a telephone they got telephone
party line yeah you know hey let me use
the phone hey get off the phone i got to
talk to somebody
that's the only way to get the phone and
we was kids in that old cable
they run that and we climb up that pole
up in the limb and get a hole that line
hit knock the day like that
we thought we'd get a hole over to see
what was going on
we didn't hold on they were at home
because it was juice on that old
it was just a piece of water what it was
so uh tell me about how you grew up you
had uh
transportation yeah well we had we got
one pair of shoes a year
and you better not wear them out because
you wouldn't you wouldn't get the mower
and we go
barefooted in summertime never went
nowhere that went by foot
we go fishing got an old creek bank
we had an old black dog and he killed
every snake in front of you he didn't
matter what kind come out he killed that
snake we didn't have to worry about the
snakes we had the dog with
so when you got down in here and then we
got up here at either sailors up here at
this pond
they had a big strawberry pack
we go fishing we went down
we're going to crawl over in this
strawberry patch
pick us a bunch of strawberries we go
crawl through them
weeds and stuff crawled up and on an old
copperhead
hey boys that was the end of the
strawberry yet
we left town we had us a water hole up
here went swimming in
well keith's cold on had an old college
dog
and if you went swimming and started
squalling and screaming
that dog come in there and if you didn't
get go to shore with him he grounded
trying to get yellow
you couldn't we get to the shore and
quit wouldn't spawn the more there's no
hollering
because the dog come in and get he
thought she wasn't drowning i'd say
tell me about how you grew up you had uh
i assume you're wow we
what we raised we what we raised what we
eat
every summer dad buy we traded
oh peach man we dread him coming around
he buy 13 bushels of peaches
we had to peel them and can them we put
300 cans of stuff in the cellar
and the patrol half that can 300 a year
every different stuff oh everything was
canned you buy nothing at the store
except necessities like meal
we take the cornbread corn over and
we'll hoi it and and have it ground
and and that way we got a meal
and dad raised honeybees at most time
that's what we use for chewing gum the
wax off
you know well it was good there was no
doubt about that
how much schooling did you get how far
did you go in school huh how far did you
go in school
went two-year high school and we and you
went to work after that
you went to work after that yeah well i
got yeah i went to north carolina
and uh down there
and when i turned 18
got right into the surf i went down my
sister
but now we had it was
we could walk up down this road when we
was kids
nobody locked their doors nobody used to
go in
we could go in and eat if they had
anything left over for
cornbread or anything go in the house
go in that old cupboard wood stove
get what you wanted nobody said nothing
nobody was never missed nothing
but now you can't walk up down here you
have to have a bell that bit them out of
here
so hit i don't mind giving people stuff
don't mind helping them but boys don't
steal something off me
that makes me madder and beautiful
and tear something up if you're gonna
tear something up tire up your own stuff
don't go around tying up somebody else
that's why i was brought up dad to scan
us alive he know we've been out
turned something up we
we'd blocked we we got out here
halloween you know we must key
my sister and everything all them
fellows up here next door
they're dressed up real fast
so we got a wise idea we went up the
road and it's coming up through there
they had pillars and stuff
we stretched the rope across the road
trip
that's about the kids if i get a hold of
you we'll kill you
and man many up here we went up to her
though
told me we're gonna trick-or-treat you
and if you don't treat us
we're gonna pile up
on what set she said okay boys okay
well we'll get she come out with a water
hose and drowned in every one of us
he said now that's the treat i'm gonna
get
he drowned into us but i mean he flat
drowned it
and uh that's the way it's here
it it said him william
old man taylor brown in school
he's rough on us but he was the best k
i i recommend him to anybody
we went on a field trip now
up on the ship where we come off the
bigelow up
to learn the trees and the pliers you
know the leaves and identify
and uh well we
all the classroom went up there too
so we went and got uh we we
got excited we'd hold hands with them
girls
yeah we're going up to the holding hands
you know
old taylor brown he never said a word
now i need my word we got back the
classroom and the school up here at
green hill
where it was at we got back the
classroom
taylor brown come out and he said now
boys
girl they said this ain't pub we ain't
in here for puppy love
he said we're in here to learn he will
wear everybody in there out he'll give
every one of them a whipping whole
classroom
yeah and people they respected him
he'd take us when we go to first grade
on the spelling bee we'd have to spell
in the first grade book we'd spell it
until we missed the word we'd go to the
second grade book
you'd spelt it you missed more than that
and everybody was repeating to stay
ahead of them
he taught me one thing he taught me
about
smoking he said tobacco
is an indian weed from the devil he
proceeds
he picks your pockets burns your clothes
and makes a chimney out you know
i say i will never forget what that long
as i live
so you never smoked no what about uh
alcohol or stuff like that
nah i
a beer every now and then what about
moonshine well you know you ship it a
little bit
your family made moonshine made
i like to have what they made everything
down this creek made moonshine there was
no house around here that
really yeah they had uh when the
revenues come in
they had a signal well if they come in
on this one
he'd pour his old shotgun three times
that means the law was in here and
everybody leave the steel and come home
and that's the way they warned one
another dad made moonshine
he would haul it um it was an old
colored fella over in
georgetown he bought everything he
bought
every gallon of moonshine dad made
dad took the backseat of the car out
he stuck his moonshine in on top of it
put a quilt and stuff over it the kids
would sit on it in the back seat and
he'd take across the mountain down
take it over to him we got over there
and uh
he told us he said boys he said i'd sure
like to have some good wine
and uh dad don't improve by anybody
so we picked a bunch of blackberries and
made him up a bunch of wine
he come over here and bought every bit
of it
so we got now they heard we gonna fish
him another bag
we got a big hurry and jarted up for it
worked
out put it in the closet in the back
room
we're sitting there at the fireplace
some pound dad said what is
that i don't know something a pound
again
we went into that that blackberry wine
was
blowing up his busting yard running
everywhere in that closet
so we had to add into the blackberry
wine making right there
we jarred it if you join it before it
works off
it'll boil oh really yeah so so what
kind of jobs have you had in your life
i've worked the mines worked now
i worked at a border shop in uh
chicago so you lived in chicago for a
while yeah how long yeah
i was about probably a year or two when
i got laid off
and i never did go back how'd you like
living in the big city
don't it'd be all right if you're out in
the country
i lived on the south side tilled in high
school there
and ever fighting every night and all
day long
so we got
we got uh we got we get up and uh
that and i said if i ever get laid off
never come back
and i ain't been back since i lay out
and you love it here
you you love it here yeah man it's the
only place to be
what do you love about applause
look at it you can see it it's beautiful
yeah
yeah but it's very poor here ain't
nobody
most of your neighbors are just like me
they go good neighbors you talk to them
you go visit them
they won't just be left alone don't go
up there and steal this or steal that go
up and ask them
and nine times out of ten they'll give
it to you
that's what it is here just this jungle
sitting right here
if you need it and know it i'll give it
to you but don't come in here and try to
steal it and take it
i mean that ain't no good dad set us
apart if he knows we stole something
we went over that boy that brother of
mine went
roman anderson buckhart on top pine
mountain here had a store
that's where dad trade we go
up fire when we was kids
and the first thing we'd do had big
cracks in the pool where he sat with his
cash director
and uh he had them uh
we go around the back and dive under
that floor and look for money
and every time we go in there under that
floor we find enough money buy some pop
in the moon pipe
i think he was feeding it down through
the
what forest able to do every time we
went up
that brother mine jr he got up
going decided stealing my pack of
cigarettes
there he stole that pack of cigarettes
dad called him with him now he said son
you're going back
up there you're gonna pay the old man
with a cigarette
and he said you're gonna wish i hadn't
set you on fire
he come back up old man booker said i
seen him get him
said i wasn't gonna say nothing he said
cause i know what if jim bought him
found them he'd wear you out and bring
him back he made
and go up there and tell the man he was
sorry and pay and play cigarette
wouldn't let him happen so
that's the way he was raised up to
respect your elder
i mean they they got no respect for
elder people
people raised up now it's they don't
care
yeah what do you think of the younger
generation here a lot of drugs are being
used well a lot of it yeah
i mean they just hate they need to get
out
any of them i did it everybody else did
it i think all these young generations
need to serve in the service
i need the draft needs to be back in
this country
because when i was at 18
couldn't find no work
and i went to the draft place down
that's about
don't be sending me a bunch of papers
like this i said just go ahead and drive
well i didn't hear them from they got me
a good job of working
two weeks i got a job to drive
so there you go so so
man do you do you consider yourself a
hillbilly huh do you consider yourself a
hillbilly
i don't know that's a hillbilly over
that's what i think right here you can't
give me nothing
i build overhauls don't
how do you define what what is a
hillbilly to you
plain old country fell like my dad's mom
was
they were here we'd walk
grandma from here she write a mule
in tamil park stay online ride that mule
on the
hide and get some groceries then ride
the mule back
in the middle park say all night come on
home the next day
and transportation it was yuri
but this was a gravel road nothing but
gravel
on it he didn't have that how i think
they
fixed that in 53 a 56 month
when did you start seeing automobiles
here huh when did you start seeing
automobiles here
that we had an automotive willow at cove
i did i tell you a gun was pulled on
he got we got up on it had no 55 or
uh 52 i believe it was a silver there
49.
how old are you huh how old are you i've
been i'm 78
78. we had some firecrackers in our hand
we got on the running board and i guess
he thought he was
riding down the road with him i guess he
thought he was supposed to let them walk
he lit the poor crackers and we had
their hair
you thought about burn boy we burnt up
and he got it we got him to pull
couldn't
you know he sought this road with frozo
we got him to pull us on a on a
when him sleds well he pulled us down
the road he stopped we kept going we
couldn't stop rapping under the truck
they were behind him on the road and we
got
my uncle up here we made us road down
the hill like
yeah well we didn't have no sleds
we got all these hickory bottom chairs
which if i had one they made that fly me
but when hit
bottom it bust all pieces of them chair
there
he's about to kill him and that old
school house that we first
went to school with was up here
above me here two-room school
and we got out my uncle they couldn't
get back then they couldn't get no sugar
much
but they made the moonshine with my wife
we got out there and got in this
smokehouse
and what we didn't just open one cat of
my lashes
everybody got a can had their fingers in
their stick
but he like he wouldn't come off of it
when he called us
he he said you're destroying me he said
you're wasting it
he said what be so bad if you just got
one he said everybody got one oak
but i can take you up here on the hill
and i can find them over molasses cans
up here where they made moonshine all
play but that
moonshine ain't that hard to make no
hand
but you got to know what you're doing to
make it
cause if you scorch it if you puke it
or any of that oh lord
you can't drink it so you're in trouble
so have you have you traveled around the
country no
no places i've been when when i was in
survey
went to chicago i went i've been to
chicago
i've been down in florida been down up
and uh
i ain't been nowhere hardly mud north
carolina north carolina yeah i was down
north carolina
and uh i went to
i took my basic training in port jackson
south carolina
took my ait in portland missouri
come back to fort houston virginia i was
in
what used to in the night in the
shipyard and uh
when kennedy got kicked up
and uh that's the most uh
when they told me i was uh got out basic
training would go
send me to little career i didn't know
what they taught me i said you ain't
sending me over
it if portland was in missouri what it
was
you had on you didn't have they nothing
it used to be an old german
princeton camp what it was so they
you didn't have nothing uh one little
town a wainful
and all the rest of it if you got a
weekend pay
was a hundred and some miles away you
couldn't do that in a weekend
so i go downtown waynesville it was
about the size of heart and went to big
and hard and that's all
it was i stayed on base
you could go to a movie for a quarter
and they had five theaters on there so
i'd go to all the theaters for a
different movie
it used to be a german prison camp what
it was it was around portland
yeah they had the old machine gun mounts
and stuff everything was still there for
it
they kept german prisoners out there
that's where we built built bridges tore
it down
build a bridge tie it down build it tie
it down
combat engineers yeah so has has life
here
uh gotten easier gotten harder
no it ain't got no no harder for me
if you know how to do it i mean i got
i don't pay no water bills i get my
mountain up here with the water
and my electricity ain't that much
i got uh i draw so scary
but you don't draw enough to pay the
bills that's reason i have to
on the side you know i sell a little
junk and stuff keep my spending money
and do you hunt for food no yeah they
plenty of
oh i feed y'all you want what kind of
stuff there's plenty elk right here
there too turkeys all that
and here you can survive in these
mountains if something goes wrong
and these cities you came yeah
it's survival out here you can do and in
the city you can't do what you can do
here
is that what makes the appalachian
people so so unique
and so strong and so i mean there's
survivors here
yeah well you can do anything like that
you know you can
you can go up here if i'm hungry i'll go
here and kill my deer
if i get hungry i'm gonna feed my family
one way or the other
where i got a license or not but if you
go in the city
you can't probably get out and kill one
of them big rats and eat it but
who would do that so it's
a survivor placement yeah so everybody
came
i see your hat you you you you voted for
trump
vote for trump support trump 100
what do you what do you like best about
what he's done huh what do you like best
about
trump but he's done for the veterans
that
nobody done we can go anywhere we want
to see a doctor now he done what
he said he was going to do he done
whatever he said
and uh i just can't see these fellas you
know out here
turn up something burning it down why
don't they go
home and burn their own house down you
know
it things are wrong but there's a way
to do it in a wrong way
if i got something against you and i
can't go to court and settle it
before well get out you're gonna burn
your house down
it's it's ridiculous but i voted for him
i vote for him again
do you have a do you have any regrets in
your life no not really
i had my wife here for 50 years and
she passed away you know i wish she she
could still be here
and how many kids do you have how many
kids do you have i got uh
let's see i'd have to count them now
i baited seven though and you raised
them
yeah yeah they're good kids every one of
them that's great
hey you can't uh you can raise you can't
let uh you gotta have this and over here
to raise if you ain't going to have kids
and raise them while why would i have
them you know
but when i was a kid
we worked up here to figure coal on
and we'd work in there just so we could
go play the pinball machine you know
we worked in there he said now boys he
said if you fellas do a man's work i'll
pay you a man's place
we gonna buy more he passed 50 cents an
hour that's what we got
and we go up there and uh and we put it
back to pass store and the pinball would
say
you know what we're done but you could
buy
you could buy we he had them on sale
a 10 pound brock candy at
christmas man that cousin i told him i
said let's buy one of them
we split on it i think it was a dollar
and a half
and i told him i said now we're gonna
have to eat this thing before we get
home
cause if you don't the big fellas to
take it away from us
many of them eat that 10 pound of candy
we never eat more candy
we were sicker than mews i think it's
going to get
wet yeah i think it's starting to rain
yeah what uh what's the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life in your 78 years
well i do what other
really i mean the bible says do what
unto others what you'd have been doing
i like to be treated just like i want to
treat somebody i won't be treated the
same way
and it's it you you can do
anything you want to do and someday
it's gonna come back on you gonna regret
so i'd like to be treated just like
everybody else
and i don't care what color you are how
you are
see grandma
was part indian other was that
indian and all of us she was a part
cherokee indian
and years ago you can't see people
turning down all the statues all the
history
especially this year this is history
and turn it down and destroying him
it what it was and why it happened
you know i mean it it's simple
but they want to tie it down destroy it
and stuff that you can't put
back they tore the old green hill school
down
they shouldn't have never done that they
should have left that there for history
and the old keyword down in keywood here
was a three-seat camp
they tore it down and history people
would have come
in here by oolens to visit and do stuff
within that
so it's that's history
and uh you know i don't regret
nothing that i've done are you a
religious man
are you religious um well if you ain't
i believe in the bible i ain't never
been joined no church
but if i don't believe if a man does
exactly what that bible says
he's going to heaven i don't care who it
is
all right man thank you so much for
talking with me yeah very interesting
story yeah
and uh good luck with uh whatever you do
from here well this
is country here yeah you're happy here
yeah it's beautiful
i'd rather be sitting on a tin can and
on a dad burn
rocking sure and have to pay for it you
know
you can make anything work the only way
to go
excellent thank you so much yeah
well you're welcome i mean you can go
around anytime you want to i'll be back
if y'all come down stairway we'll run
y'all worst country
how many generations do you think this
property's been in your family
your grandma was a hundred and almost
102 when she died
so it's been here ever since
they used to own grandpa and them did
on from the head of the creek all this
back to here they used to run
and they sold it to our chilean company
with oklahoma
then out there then they packed up come
back here and say
they had saved this if they ever wanted
to come back
and they come back here and we
bought a big farmer in oklahoma you're
not leaving i
know i'm not going nowhere
i wouldn't give this for all the cities
in the world
it's beautiful here yeah well you got
plenty
i get my water back on
it's about a thousand feet up y'all
we're dead and then my moon yeah
oh that's for you
there's people in chicago and places
give their neck to get